the Dutch judges entered the special
court near Amsterdam Schiphol Airport in
solemn silence at the start of a trial
of mass murder
faylene had longer days oekaki Nadezhda
many have waited a long time for this
day the day that the mh17 criminal trial
really begins as a consequence of this
atrocious disaster 298 people men women
and children died a case of this
complexity and magnitude is
unprecedented in the Netherlands among
the dead 80 children
entire families gone and now four men
stand accused of their deaths three
Russians and a Ukrainian they were named
by investigators as Igor girkin
a former colonel in Russia's FSB
intelligence service he was given the
title of Minister of Defence in
separatist-held eastern Ukraine two
suspected members of Russia's military
intelligence that GRU are also on trial
Sergei Dubinsky and Oleg part of the
fourth suspect is Ukrainian national
Leonid Kharchenko
believed to be a pro-russian separatist
commander all four men were absent from
court believed to be in Russia arrest
warrants have been issued but Russia
doesn't extradite its citizens and the
Kremlin's questioned the legitimacy of
the court the trial will continue
without them I do hope the judge had so
many evidence on this table that he can
come to one conclusion guilty as
relatives who you are looking very
forward to start off this process
because it's so important to find the
truth the joint investigation team
formed by Australia Belgium Malaysia the
Netherlands and Ukraine found that the
plane was shot down by a Russian buk
surface-to-air missile system brought
into Ukraine from Russia this is the
crime scene reconstructed from remaining
wreckage the Kremlin denies involvement
it was meant to have been a routine
flight from amsterdam to kuala lumper
instead the passengers of the boeing
triple-seven became victims of a foreign
war
if found guilty the four suspects could
face life in prison little is known
about who will testify before the court
the identities of some witnesses may
remain secret in a trial that's expected
to take several years to reach a verdict
Nev Barker al-jazeera